hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to state of decay now this
is a game that came out about six months
ago and it was on the Xbox Live at first
and only recently came to PC um I saw a
friend of mine play this and it looked
pretty interesting as a zombie RPG based
building type of community building city
builders style thing it's interesting
game I can't really say um I only
started two games just to test out what
it was like and I just wanted to get
into it and get a feel for it but I
don't know much about this game all I
know is that you kill zombies as far as
my gameplay you kill zombies that's
about all I did maybe they look a little
rotten Sara zombie prancing in the
background back there came out here is
anyone else do that damn sure maybe we
can find some help there
alright ranger station it is I swear I
saw a zombie prancing around in the
flowers Oh like a golf club holy hell
well good thing all that practice at the
driving rain paid off hahaha good joke
there markiplier thank you your ass
first
ok I need to get to the ranger station
where that is I got a mini-map and a GTA
style stuff going on when the left stay
exactly this low and this quiet what
does that mean all my stick is gone oh
no I just pull right out of my ass
enough lollygagging we gotta go eat a
snack for a temporary stamina boots goop
all over the floor okay here's the
ranger station
is it just mirrored the shadows in this
game look really dark
shouldn't there be some ambient
reflective lighting going on here
maybe I'm winded got bigger problems
than that buddies man can anybody tell
me what the hell is going on what's
going on is there's more of them up here
than I expected
we need to sweep the rest of the cabins
for survivors okay I've got injured
people here I have to tend to okay we'll
see what we can do what you will
I appreciate it there's a water tower
out back that has a good view of the
campgrounds might be worth your while to
climb up there and have a look around
first we've got some supplies in the
locker over there take what you need and
stay safe aren't they worried at all
about Who I am the first rule in a
zombie apocalypse is not to trust anyone
and here this guy uses as we're just
friends you take whatever we have in the
locker are not gonna question game logic
there's just to get us going as quick as
possible okay there's nothing in here oh
wait no fool
ooh what is that and that how do I get
that how do I get that I don't know Oh
take space got it equip with Q all right
sorry I'm getting used to this still I'm
gonna take all of your junk don't give
me that please okay take that all right
there we go now equip that and we're
good how do I get out of this close with
this gate got it all right still
learning but now we're out you're gonna
go
okay my objective he's said to get up in
a tower he's talking about this good
sight lines up there really doesn't seem
like that good I think I do have a
stamina bar on the look Oh God I didn't
hurt it all or did it is that my health
bar on the right there I have no idea
yeah oh my god I'm so sorry I think my
head just went straight up your ass oh
my god what happened okay right mouse
button to survey I'm they're gonna take
a look around
uh-huh camp site camp site is that
dust-filled supply store vehical you
things are awfully close by wanna check
out why that building in particular and
who is this dorky looking doofus anyway
friend of mine I'm guessing what
happened was this guy went out camping
and then when he came back um all hell
broke loose and then everyone trust
everyone and no one fights anyone I
think I've seen enough for now
okay these days though did you please
please a little bit of personal space
there
Edgar wait why can't I see where the
things are now I can't even do it if I
surveying oh I see wait no it's Dave
yeah okay here we go
I'm gonna check here first cuz it's kind
of telling me to and then the distance
gunshots over there okay this was the
building that he specifically said that
I should check out so I'm gonna assume
then excuse me he knows what he's
talking about
hello is anybody here hello I was
actually pretty interested in the game
if I if I'm joking around uh ignore me
I'm just trying to be you stupid IDI
bastard I'm tired and I please
I'm almost dead - holy crap this game is
not easy apparently I should have known
when there were whole dude there wasn't
a difficulty modifier so obviously this
game might be a little hard but bear
with me by the way I'm not gonna be
playing through this game and in its
entirety I'm just gonna be I don't even
know if there is an end to this game any
chance we can just hole up here with the
last of the tequila until this all blows
over somehow yeah probably not there
buddy pounds
ooh wait what were you talking about
were you talking to oh that gun oh well
let's get him I don't know if there's
any durability to the weapons oh my god
oh and now he's dead you killed him and
he had the magic of flight he could have
taught us many things there such thing
is flying zombie that would only be if
zomb ism superpowers like it left for
dead
not alone in here I don't see anything
on the mini-map thumb and assume you're
lying
who is it who's there
no girls allowed oh you're a guy I'm so
sorry still increase that's the RPG
element I knew there was something to it
other than what you stopped talking to
the zombies please kind of hard to pick
them out from the foliage everything
kind of has the same e style look and I
swear I'm at 1080p playing the game but
it looks like a much lower resolution I
don't know why leveled up oh cool so
cool you know whit's how do I do
how do I know how do I know what I do I
don't know what I do oh I see I just
level them up all individually I don't
have like skills or anything that I can
okay how many beds or how population's
ah gotta get the population up if you
know what I mean oh cool it's like you
got them it's like a um you got a man
supplies of your community while you're
kind of goes up so then you can uh
struggles to survive
come here zom zom got a present for you
well you don't like it I'll too bad
anyway so that was one down I swore that
I was looking at these tents over here
but I don't know if it did anything
gimme violin Mormons the Mormons from
the cynical video the Mormons uh after
the zombie apocalypse is why are you
here
they took desperate measures is this the
glowy that's a glowy
search faster make noise how much noise
could I possibly make searching found a
gun like with that yes please get that
there who wants the piece here what whoa
don't just do that well [ __ ] really
that's my number three is my emote
button just like say random [ __ ] that's
on your mind oh yeah yeah oh [ __ ] I
actually do have dance move yeah okay
enough of that enough [ __ ] around I
kick around way too much in games I just
try to have you've been saying that a
lot Edgar but um I don't think these
guys want to be reason he flew
constantly beating on this the same guy
okay
it was a bigger building over here
returning whoa whoa whoa whoa
return to mission area what does that
even mean
I didn't even know I was on a mission
what okay I've got a blue arrow over
there
guessing that's where I need to go sorry
I am still brand new to this game but
it's actually a lot of fun it's it's
pretty cool it's well put together it
plays well it's got a good game feel I
mean other than the silliness that I've
been doing is it it's actually pretty
interesting I'm probably gonna do like
um maybe three or four parts on this I
don't know oh my I don't feel so good
and if you guys want more maybe I'll do
more I'll be doing excuse me Edgar wow
what happened oh he's over there just be
get out the window what the hell how did
you get in there could you let me in
maybe Edgar I've become one of them
grand
my name is excuse me I need to get in
here and wow I'm just gonna barricade
this now I okay why here
okay all right settle down there game I
was just complimenting you let's take
him back a couple not settle down a bit
ooh
Twinkies I need one of these because I'm
about to die I can't take more probably
good idea that they don't take more and
what's in the bed roll here searching
anything oh there seems to is that a few
- no that's suitcase I thought that was
a fuel canister but it's a suitcase and
a gatorade container okay I think that's
about all there is define you leave that
long you got it girl
check out those gunshots we heard oh
wait they were oh there they are okay
all right I'm gonna check those out
because I'm not ready to go back to the
campus yet I'm doing just fine surviving
in the woods
look bathroom oh look a park look a park
area let's have a barbecue oh there's
his arms I'm chasing me I swear I don't
even see them but they oh there's one I
don't see him says there's stuff on my
mini-map but I do not see him - breather
oh there is uh Edgar um there's a
prancing zombie uh is that the zombie I
stop prancing around in the flower field
earlier I swear I swear that probably
shouldn't be that funny to be but it's
really really silly okay continuing on
trying to find what the women
yeah there he goes his head exploded his
head exploded all over you I don't know
if these are the type of zom zoms where
there's an infection or they only come
back when you're dead or something
excuse me don't shoot me please why do
they do that
what yeah lady coming for you I'm coming
to help beautiful lady how do I quit
this well yeah I hope we got some
survivors back at the ranger station
that seem to know what's going on but we
didn't have time for orientation mm-hmm
Oh take point cuz my good credible
leadership oh look at this it's a
beautiful this is beautiful oh look it's
the prancing zombie you go guys
you do a great job okay let's go back
damn after I'm done praising the plebs
[Music]
my business do-do-do-do-do oh look it's
a zombie
come at me bro come at me get him get
him guys get him cuz apparently I can't
use my gun good job
you're the best
nothing ever gonna keep you down exactly
really I'm having a blast playing this
by the way I'm not making fun of this
just because of the some quirks of the
game I'm legitimately having fun here
this is this is my have fun face look at
me look I know how to have fun okay
anything in here porn no seriously how
do I gun how do I gun it says I'm
equipped on it do I gone hey you know
what I have this twig I'm gonna use it
really I can use a together
oh right mouse button to aim and then
thing that is like that other game that
did the thing were you right about what
I don't know but I just leveled up in
cardio like that wouldn't it be great if
like you were in the middle of a jog and
you're really tired after like the third
mile and you're like oh why do I even do
this I feel fantastic and then you load
in white glowy yellow and everyone
looked a hell I thought you said you had
survivors holed up in here oh they were
fine just a minute ago uh-oh obviously
not anymore
Oh Oh guys guys come on oh I didn't even
see the bodies dead on the floor oh man
don't do it Edgar Edgar don't do it I'll
do it Edgar Haggar yeah
don't be like don't be stupid don't add
don't do it no do so stupid oh we're
just standing here watching it happen
[Music]
edie why I knew I swear to God that guy
he was dead
how the hell does that happen I don't
know man doesn't make sense we can't
stay here come on let's grab what we can
and get movie um aren't we gonna do
something with the whole Edgar situation
about him being directly bit in a
cutscene and everyone knows that if you
get hurt in a cutscene that's when you
really get hurt in a video game anyway
okay so anyway this is a ton of fun I'm
gonna do I'm gonna record a few more
parts right now but I'm all out of time
for this episode um let me know what you
think of the comments below if you want
to see more a link for the game is in
the description it's not free by the way
but it is a full game so hence why it's
not it's not I think it's 20 bucks I
believe maybe on sale I don't know so
anyway thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Applause]
[Music]